عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه جديده استهدفت
مدينه ومخيمه جنين بالضفه الغربيه ادت الى
سقوط فلسطينيين برصاص قناصه لاحتلال الذين
اعتلوا بنايات وسط جنين دون ان تكون هناك
اشتباكات المسلحه في المكان وفق شهود
عليها
ان وصلت الاسعاف مباشره
مهشمه وجوههم ممزقه
ولا اموات ولا اي شيء
المقاومه الفلسطينيه باذرعها العسكريه
المختلفه اكدت انها تتصدى الاعتداءات
لاحتلال الاسرائيليين وانها تدافع عن
المخيم مهما كان الثمن المخيم محرم على
هذا الاحتلال ونحن جاهزون لمعركه مخيم
جنين كبرى جديده على ارض المخيم لننتقم
لكل دماء شهداءنا الابرار التي يقوم
الاحتلال باستهداف شعبنا الفلسطيني في كل
مكان
ياتي تصعيد الاحتلال ومشاهد التشييع
اليوميه في وقت تؤكد فيه الحكومه
الفلسطينيه ان حكومه الاحتلال من خلال
تصريحات مسؤوليها المتطرفين وتهديداتهم
تحاول اشعادا المنطقه وتدفعها نحو مزيدا
من التوتر وتفجير الاوضاع
شعور الجناه القتله همم الارهابيين همم
بالافلات من العقاب المستفيدين من سياسه
المعايير المزدوجه همم يشجعهم على ارتكاب
المزيد من جرائمهم عدم العقاب يعني ان
جرائم خطيره اخرى قادمه في الطريق وقد
بلغت حصيله الشهداء في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
منذ بدايه هذا العام
215 بينهم اكثر من 55 شهيدا من محافظه
جنين ومخيمهامها
بين استمرار الاحتلال في سياسه قتل
الفلسطينيين والاعتقال والهدم والملاحقه
دون مسائله او محاسبه مواعيد المقاومه
بالثار لشهدائها تبقى المنطقه مرشحه لمزيد
من التصعيد الامني في ظل انسداد اي افق
سياسيه ينهي الصراع القائم سمير ابو شماله
الجزيره جنين فلسطين